Hello everybody, welcome to another Zoom call, it is September 10th, I'm sure everybody's
heard the horrible news about Charlie Kirk, and I'm just, I don't know, I don't have anything
to say, it's just unbelievable. But let's get on with some questions here, remember to remind
everybody to look at the announcements. Last week, we were able to have a Zoom call, I
apologize for that kind of emergency come up, but let's get to your questions. First question,
I do reduce my, if I want to reduce my total supplement load, what can I do? So if I want
to reduce my total supplement load, where can I start? So if a person has, if a person
is in complete remission, and they're doing really good, then they can start thinking
about possibly cutting back on their supplements. But if your cancer is roaring, then I wouldn't
think that way, but certainly getting another cheek swab is the way to go. So some people
are saying that they can't enter the member site. But hopefully you guys got on the member
site, right? Through the Zoom call and the member site, people that are on it right now.
But so really, if you want to, if you're concerned about taking too many supplements, yes, there
are, you know, I'm for different times with different people, for different reasons. I've
categorized their supplements upon, you know, how, you know, they're, you know, what's the
most important to the least important of their eight supplements or 12 supplements? I know
a lot of people come to us, they're taking a lot of supplements that they were currently on.
And I've said, okay, if you feel like I'm leading to take that supplement, that's just fine,
but make sure you take the ones that tested for you. There are certainly things that you could
possibly drop off over time. So again, to get retested with that request, we can definitely categorize
your supplements to see which ones are more important than others. Next question, I am, have you heard
about or done any research on hydrogen-rich water? It's been shown to be beneficial in mitigating
oxidative stress and do damage through its anti-inflammatory and apoptonic pathways, helping cardiovascular
health, liver health, and even mental health. Yes, so I've heard a lot about that. And
we've talked about this before. So I have no trouble with hydrogen-rich water. I don't see any
contradicative studies, nor evidence just thinking about the physiology towards cancer. So there's
certain things that are fine to do, but if if cancer, they're not so fine to do. No hydrogen-rich water,
hydrogenated water. There's hydrogenators, machines that you can purchase that will hydrogenate
water for you. You can put hydrogen tablets in water in a, let's say a bottle of water and
can shake it up, and that's how you can get hydrogen waters as well. It's been popular for a long time.
There's Dr. Halter and Ues to work for me years ago. Some of you may remember her.
She is a rep for a company on a floater that sells bottles that are that hydrogenate to your water,
I believe. So they can be good things. It can be good for you. So it's another thing that can
be good for you. All right, next question. If I have to take an antibiotic, what should I do
to help with my gut? Well, the study's out there. If you have to take an antibiotic, let's say you have
an acute infection, you have a bladder infection, you have a strep infection, you have to take an
antibiotic, you just had a tick bite and you look like it's inflamed, look nasty. There's issues with it,
and you have to take an antibiotic. All the studies that are out there say if you take a probiotic,
at the same time you're taking an antibiotic, that's the key to the most protective,
measure. When you're on the end of a scoop, I'll start taking a probiotic after I'm done with
this five days of antibiotic. Well, the study shows if you take it with your antibiotic, which I would
say take one with each antibiotic pill and take one in the afternoon and off a couple hours away from
the antibiotic, take several antibiotics, probiotics when you're taking an antibiotic, does far
a better job than waiting till you're done with the antibiotic. So take a probiotic with your
antibiotic. The other things you could do after you're done is take some gut healing products. So
different things like deglycerize, licorice, slippery, elm, marshmallow, things like that can be
extremely healing to the gut. Products like immunoglobulins, like SBI protect can be healing to the gut
and clean it out, butarate products can help with initiating gut healing. So there's a lot of gut
protective things that you could do and things you could do, you know, post antibiotic use as well.
So next question. So somebody asked this question and I posted the question and then I posted a
little chart with it. So how do I help heal from H. Pylori? A lot of people have H. Pylori issues. I
have a blog post on H. Pylori and please go to our blog and look at that blog post on H. Pylori.
But here's some examples. If you have an H. Pylori infection, you definitely have
gastritis issues, decrease H. C. L. production of your stomach is the precursors to H. Pylori.
Remember, helicobacter pylori is part of our normal flora and it's what it's overgrowth and this takes
over and then can go systemic beyond the stomach and the intestinal tract that we really have issues.
So it is a bacterium. It's a gram negative bacterium. So it is an infection. It is the cause of
stomach ulcers and duodenal ulcers and esophageal ulcers that the standard medical
approach to H. Pylori is to give an antibiotic which will kill it if it's in the stomach.
If H. Pylori is one of those because it is part of the normal flora as well, it can evade antibiotics.
If it's in systemic, so if you have a systemic H. Pylori infection, it's affected your
your endothelial cells, your vascular endothelium, which is a which is common, you know, with a systemic
H. Pylori infection, systemic antibiotic use tends not really to deal with it because it can evade
antibiotics. So it is something you need to work on with alternative methods, you know,
typically I do not recommend you take antibiotics for H. Pylori infection. Let's see, I'm
full-blown stomach ulcers that it might be appropriate to take antibiotics for a short period of time.
It's always accompanied by hypochloridria. You're always going to have gastritis issues
and the worst thing that you can possibly do for H. Pylori is to think that you have too much
stomach acid and go on some protein pump inhibitor. It will give you symptom relief but it's going to
cause the problem to become worse and that's how you end up moving H. Pylori systemically.
So you need to be taking H, HCl and digestive enzymes. If you have a stomach ulcer and really
damage to your stomach wall, you might not be able to tolerate that and you might have to just start
with apple cider vinegar and I have that protocol on our blog post or you have to start with this
just deglycerized licorice supplementation and just start healing the stomach wall and then go
to apple cider vinegar and then move to HCl and digestive enzymes. But things like Burberry,
oregano, garlic and some of these that are listed in this chart can be really helpful and healing
intestinal barrier support. Of course, if you have cancer, you can't take an elglutamine,
but some of these other things you certainly can be taking with cancer. So Burberry, our Burberry
clear pro is very effective for H. Pylori. Our paraclear is also very effective for H. Pylori.
Next question. Will the sauna help with mycotoxins? So I had a little extra time today. So when people
said to the question, I actually pulled up some articles on this question and the next question.
So here's actually an article that says, you know, heat is a great thing, you know, whether it's a
sauna, either conventional sauna or infrared sauna, it doesn't make any difference. It's the heat
that could really help you detoxify through the skin. That's, I would say this forever.
Oh, is it the infrared sauna? That's the best one. That doesn't make any difference. It's the
sweating in the sauna that makes the difference. So whenever we'll make you sweat, even if you don't
need to have a sauna, if you live down south and it's in the middle of the summer, you go out and
guard and you sweat like a pig, sweating is going to be a super beneficial way to help you
detoxify mycotoxins. So it helps you detoxify everything. It's going to help you detoxify heavy
metals and everything else. But this study proved that mycotoxins detoxify through the skin. Well,
we could do a study on heavy metals and other toxins that you might find in the toxic detect test.
You're going to detoxify it through your skin if you're sweating like a stump pig. So that's the
benefit of a sauna. That's the benefit of going outside and working outside and sweating. It's
going to really help it to take pressure off the liver and the kidneys to detoxify your getting rid
of stuff. So very, very beneficial. This question or sorry, the same question, but I pulled up another
thing. This another study on mycotoxins, the show that okrotoxins are found in human sweat. So the
more you can sweat, just another good study of sweating is beneficial. So the more you can sweat,
the more pressure you can take off your liver, the more pressure you can take off your kidneys,
it's extremely beneficial. Here's another question. Is it okay to take different
brands of supplements other than the ones you tested? It's okay, you could do whatever you want,
but when I test this supplement, sometimes the brand is important. So I know there's other brands
out there that can be far less expensive. There's a lot of influencers out there that push their
own brands and they private label things just like we do. Unfortunately, there's a lot of them that
private label real cheap. Sorry, but crappy supplements because they can get them so much cheaper and
then they can make a whole lot more money off them because they honestly just don't care about
it. It's just volume. They don't they don't have you as a patient. They just has you as a
supplement customer purchaser. So they don't care about you personally. They just want to sell
supplements. And I'm not judging everybody's personality, but you have to understand there's been
studies done where independent companies have taken different brands of supplements and tested them
for actually the truth in labeling and it's it's it's unbelievable. Some have zero, you know,
of the combination that's listed of, you know, 500 milligrams of activation, it had zero in there
was all just rice ground rice flour. So you do have to be careful with different supplements. And
just because it has some influencers day about it does not mean it's a good quality supplement.
So just just know that you you do have to be careful. And when I test you on different things, I'm
testing you the supplement that I'm testing you on. So you are taking not saying it's a big risk.
I'm just saying it's a risk. So you're going with a with an off brand supplement even if it's a big
influencers name of the brand. Excuse me. Next question. What are your thoughts on using peptides?
Not ozemic in all those ones. Some combinations I've looked at for perimenopause and this person
lists five different peptides for perimenopause. Out of these right here, the only one that I would
say that I would approve is the BPC157 and the thimosin beta four. The other ones are meant to
stimulate an increase metabolic rate. And so you would not want to do that for cancer. So there's
certain peptides that, you know, if you're trying to increase metabolic rate, which can
increase like like the test of morland helps with visceral fat loss. Well, it does so by
increasing metabolic rate. Well, you don't want to increase metabolic rate with a person with cancer.
Now what let's say a person, I don't have cancer anymore. Can I start taking these?
Yes, you just have to be careful with some of these. There's not a decade's worth of studies on what
this does to the human body. So that's the only thing that I would caution you about it. I've read
read multiple books on peptide therapy. I know several of my friends that are practitioners that are
doing peptide therapy. It shows some promise and make some physiological sense, but it also,
you just don't know what you're messing with. So I personally would be cautious about it
and go slow with anything that I would do, because you know, there could be some reports of some
negative effects of those things. So I would just be careful about it. Okay, we do apologize. A lot
of people are not able to get on the zoom call tonight, because something was wrong with the member
cited. Just did is working on that. So it is made for it. So everybody will be able to watch it
in just a few minutes. So Patty says I entered directly through the zoom app. I just came across a
study that showed taking a probiotic with or post antibiotic actually slowed recovery of healthy
microbiota. I thought I sent it to you. And then another person said is absolute lymphocyte,
monocyte, neutrophil, eosinophil, and basophil in blood tests better to be closer to the lower range
or higher range. If it is closer to the lower range, as this means there is activity in the body
to raise it, or does it mean the immune system is weak. So it depends on which one we're talking about.
So your absolute, this is called your differential on your CBC. So when you do a CBC, you are looking
at the total white blood cell count, total red blood cell count, and then the factors of red blood cell
differentiating anemia. And then the differential of the white blood cell count is breaking out lymphocytes
and then you understand that you could do a further study of lymphocytes that have a lymphocyte panel
and break that down into T cells, T hemp ourselves, B cells, etc. Natural killer cells and such.
But the differential is going to show percentage of lymphocyte, monocyte, neutrophil,
eosinophil, basophil, and then an absolute value of those things. So is it better to be closer
to the low end or closer to the high end? Well, it is it better to be either. It's better to be
in the middle. So what you're really looking for, if your white blood cell count is within normal
limits, then typically there's not much to look at when we, there's not as big a reason to look
at the differential. So it's when the white blood cell count, the total white blood cell count is
abnormal. Then we want to look at the differential. So if my white blood cell count is 5.0, which is
like perfect, then there's really not a need to look at the differential. The only reason I would
is if I had some had immune symptoms, let's say I had really bad allergies, that I might still
look at the differential and I might see eosinophils being really high. Now what does that tell you?
Does it tell you that you can manipulate that? No, but it is a, it's a sign that you have really
bad allergies. So if you have really bad allergies, you might have elevation of eosinophils. It doesn't
mean that you can manipulate that somehow with a supplement or a drug to lower the eosinophils
and then my allergies are going to go away. No, I have elevated eosinophils because I have allergies.
Just like, okay, let's say my, my total white blood cell count is low because I have a suppressed
immune system. Could be because I have cancer, could be because I have a chronic infection for years.
There's lots of reasons why I have a low white blood cell count, but then let's say my lymphocytes
are low and my due to, let's say all of them are low. Well, does it mean I can manipulate that? No,
you want to find out why it's low. So you would do some investigation to find out why it's low. Do
I have a chronic infection or if I already know I have a diagnosis of cancer, that could be my why.
But let's say I've recovered from cancer. I'm doing so much better. I feel great. Why do I still
have only a 3.5 white blood cell count? Well, then you could do some more investigation to
why it is. Do I have a chronic infection that may be
precipitated by cancer? I don't know. We could do some investigation. Or if your total white
blood cell count is high, let's say it's 8.0, which is still with the normal range, but it's higher
than it should be. Then we could look at the differential and say my lymphocyte count is high
also compared to my neutrophilus. So it could be I have an acute viral infection. So if my white
blood cell count is elevated, and I know I don't have a white blood cell cancer like a leukemia or
something, then if my white blood cell count is elevated, that's typically an acute infection.
And then you would differentiate whether it's elevated neutrophils, quite possibly a bacterial
infection, or elevated lymphocytes, quite possibly a viral infection. So if I have just really slightly
elevated total white blood cell count, let's say it's 7. And then eocidophils are really high. It could
be because of environmental allergies that I'm exposed to. So that's how you look at that. It's not
better to have them to the lower range or better to have them to the higher range. It doesn't make a
difference if they're at the lower range or the higher range, but you're looking at the total white
blood cell count. So then you're using the differential to differentiate what could possibly be going on.
Uh, okay, next question from the chat. Are there any other pro-wave, iron pro-wave
foot programs in a rife? I did a search for iron. It did not see any bottom. Should I maybe use
another search term? So in your true rife, if you have a true rife, you have a folder that says
iron pro-wave. So don't do a search. Look, in the folders, you should have an iron pro-wave folder
with a bunch of programs in that. Next question from the chat. You recommended a product to me
micropole because of high micotoxid levels. What would you recommend for docine?
Okay, so your levels of microphilogenic acid were really high, if I remember.
So they were real high, but you could be excreted a lot. So maybe we talked about that. So maybe that's
why they were high because you're doing a good job of dumping them. So one or two per day, I mean,
typically I recommend one per day. But if you want to see if you could pull faster, you could go
with two a day. If you are supporting all the other stages of detoxification. So if you're
supporting, if you're having a good vulnerable with, that's phase six of detoxification. If you feel
like your liver is doing well, you're not having pain on your right side. And make sure you're doing
other things like coffee enemies and putting hot packs over your liver, castor hot packs over your
liver to support that. If you're doing those things that you can certainly take more key lady
binding type supplements. But if you're like constipated a lot, then you've got to go slower and
you should not be taking more than one a day if that. What are your thoughts on photodynamic therapy?
Are you aware of anything we can do at home? For instance, Blue Light Plus Curriculum and Cream
has a sensitizing agent to treat skin cancer and breast tumors close to skin. Or is it too complex
to do at home? So photodynamic therapy is the problem with that is that is is a junk male term.
Because we could say that you're doing photodynamic therapy by doing exactly what you're saying.
You're using Blue Light or Red Light or Green Light therapy with a cream over
treating a skin cancer. I would say I would say I absolutely do that at home, something like that.
But thinking that you're going to get a deep systemic change other than skin deep changes
with doing photodynamic therapy is questionable, even in the realm. So technically when photodynamic
therapy came out, they were using lasers internally with a sensitizing agent to affect the breast tumor
or something like that. And then there's all sorts of companies that were making photodynamic therapy
units that were simply very low-level lasers that okay, if you're really doing a, so lasers
are graded from a level one to a level four laser. So a level four laser is a very strong laser.
And if you put a different head out of you can actually do surgery with a level four laser.
But the level one laser would be almost to the level of a laser pointer or just using Blue Light
therapy or Red Light therapy as your photodynamic piece to the therapy. Now you're not going to have
any benefit to that other than skin deep. But if you're trying to do something on the skin by all means,
do go for it. But if you think you're going to have effects deeper, even several millimeters deep
to if your if a breast cancer was that close to the surface, you're not going to have effects.
Now if the breast cancer was open and it was already at the surface, now you could have therapy
doing that. So by all means, you don't do things that are topical like that. Next question on the
chat. I know you've said that bone or meat broth isn't good for cancer patients because of the
glutamate glutamine in it. Is vegetable stock okay? Yes, vegetable stock is fine. So you don't have the
excess glutamine from vegetable stock. So yes, go for that. Next question. If if I have seasonal allergies,
it's that is that a symptom of gut problem? Since now it seems like everything is gut gut gut.
Regardless, during symptoms, is it better to try to tough it out? Or is it less stressful on your
immune system just to take it in history? So seasonal allergies is typically not a gut problem,
but it can be a barrier problem. So seasonal allergies can be a buccosal barrier issue with the
nasal buccosal barrier and respiratory buccosal barrier. So it can still be a barrier problem,
which is a gut barrier problem. So you can still take some things that will help build those barriers.
But you certainly can have antibodies to different things that you've developed antibodies to different
things that you're breathing in like polyd and things like that. So is it bad to should I tough it
out or should I take it in a histamine? I'd say take it in a histamine. So there's natural
histamine things like we have clear histamine, scavenger, and products like that that have
course it to the other things that are actually good for cancer patients as well. But a medicine
over the counter at a histamine can actually be good for a cancer patient. So there's studies
and I have them on the website and I think I have them in the cancer course that I've had them in my
book about the benefits of over the counter at the histamines. The studies were on breast cancer
but it can be attributed to just about any cancer. So I don't think there's anything wrong with taking
it over the counter in a histamine. Next question. I have some dental work coming up. Lower right
molar usually difficult to get me numb. This issue is at the gum line and I will it will be a hard
procedure. Do you have any recommendation? Today's I might do to make be a little stronger to get
through this. Well, I would say, you know, first I'll run your rife programs on dental foci and
all the dental programs that are on your rife number one. As far as getting through this, I don't know
if you mean the aftermath or the pain that you might be suffering after the procedure or the
amility to get numb through this. Some people don't react well to novocade. They tend to just be
very fast detoxers. Just genetically and novocated. It just is on their system in a second and it
doesn't work at all for them. Make sure that if that is the case with you, they're just going to have to
give you more or try to use something else. I don't I'm not familiar with the dental procedures to do
that. As far as getting through, if you mean getting stronger to get through it, the thing is you
just want to do everything you can to improve your immune system so that whatever procedure you're doing
you don't end up with an infection or something like that. So taking immune boosters would help.
If you tend to be a person that detoxifies this quickly and so novocade doesn't work on you, you
may consider a couple days before the surgeries stop taking any detoxifying agents that you're taking.
I don't know. That's wise or not, but it may help you be able to tolerate the procedure.
I sent you a new study on probiotics at info at Connors Clinic email. Okay, to send it again. Yes,
you can send it again. We can talk about that next week.
So there, you know, there's a lot of studies that probably know we think that we're going to take
probiotics and we're going to change our gut. And that's really going to help my gut. It can be
beneficial. I'm not saying that. But if you think you're going to re-floorize your gut, you think you're
going to build your microbiota by simply taking probiotics. You missed the point. You build your
microbiota and your microbiota changes quite quickly with the foods that you eat. So if you
go out of vacation, everybody's probably experienced this and your diet changes, you know, drastically
because you're out of vacation, you can be constipated for two days because your microbiota is just
completely thrown in a loop. You go home and you get back on your regular diet and it seems to
settle down and everything calms down instantly. Your microbiota changes quickly.
But it changes due to the foods that you eat. What are the worst habits that we can get into
as Americans because we can go to the grocery store and get anything we want? We tend to have
a habit of eating the same thing all the time. And even if it's something good for us,
the lack of variety in our diet really affects the diversity of our microbiota. There's been
plenty of studies that the diversity in our microbiota is based upon the diversity of different foods
in our diet. So it is a catch-22 for a number of people that have, you know, really
damage got borders and they have antibodies to all sorts of different dietary proteins. So they're
limited to their diet. It's a difficult catch-22 to healing those people because if you want to
diversify your microbiota, you have to diversify your food. So eat as many different vegetables as
possible. I know we tend to, oh, we eat corded beans and potatoes every night. Okay, that's not good.
Of course, cord is a grade, but that's not part of the discussion. If you're eating the same thing
all the time, that's not really good for your gut. So if you want the healthy, diverse microbiota,
you want as diverse a diet as possible, meaning as many different types of vegetables as possible,
different meats, different things in your diet, different fruits, not just the same thing all the time.
And again, I've said this over and over over the years. So, you know, the danger of our grocery store
habits these days is you could go and buy apples any time of the year. And I'm not saying
apples are bad for him to say that, you know, I think we're supposed to eat things and seize it and
our diets are supposed to rotate and change a lot because I think our microbiota is supposed to change
and be diverse and that's how we protect against things like we talked about earlier, like an
H. Polona infection, where you just have one rogue bacteria that goes wild and causes all sorts of
disease. So, okay, any other questions? Well, I implore you to be praying for each other. We are living
in a very turbulent time and it is evident with what has going on today, which are the currently
praying for his family, his little children, his wife, that we live in a very turbulent time
where intolerance is massive and we need to be even more in prayer for one another and then ever
before. It's just evidence that we need the Lord and this world needs the Lord.
And this is just evidence of demonic evil activity and the only thing that's going to help is prayer.
So, I just asked that you guys heard prayer for the evil that's going on.
You know, we see it in our practice. We're constantly being attacked. Things are going to
be shut down. Things don't work as they should and we just know that the devil is at work. We
just need everybody to be praying. So, God bless everybody and we'll see you next week.